when you started early did you have a
particular Mentor or an outside voice
that was helpful maybe an investor was
there someone like that that you
connected to during the early days of
odoo no I I don't have a single person I
I read a lot I used to read two books
per week no I think I'm closer to to my
book about management product or
psychology or everything that's useful
for the business
no I think I'm closer to two or three
per months but so I get IDs from a lot
of different person but there is not one
single person that influenced the way I
I am but you're reading two books a week
that's impressive yeah now I'm closer to
three per month so I decrease
but I have done that for a lot of time
yes
several years